back when the british empire was
colonizing all of this land
they drew a line the line went right
along this little mountain range
and it was meant as a boundary back in
london they were saying that no english
settler was allowed to settle west of
this line
the british empire did this because they
were worried that if settlers started to
expand into the west they would bring
the british empire into a war with
native populations
they also didn't want to unnecessarily
piss off france who also had land
in the west so they told their settlers
to settle but
not past this line and then the settlers
completely ignored it
[Music]
these settlers would eventually declare
independence from britain and start
their own country
and from there the floodgates were open
for westward expansion
a frontier people had remade a continent
virtually all productive land had been
put to the plow a free and independent
way of life
prevailed this westward blitz was made
possible through the mass slaughter of
people who were living on this land
which this little time lapse
ignores how that all went down will be
the subject of another video
but right now i want to talk about what
happened when the u.s got
here it's the mid-1800s and the us has
27 states and a bunch of territories in
the west
but the country doesn't stretch from sea
to shining sea quite yet
at this point they start to bump into
the recently independent country of
mexico
the northern part of mexico was called
tejas or texas
and it was populated mainly with native
groups who had nothing to do with the us
or mexico they had just been living
there for centuries so mexico is looking
at this
fairly new sparsely populated part of
their country and thinking what you know
what do we do with all this land they
wanted to incentivize people to go
and settle in this land so it would
potentially be more economically
productive for the country of mexico
so they made a plan they started to rent
huge swaths of land
to american settlers so they would come
in
and settle the land and in return these
american settlers would recruit
more settlers to come in and settle the
land again
all with the hope that it would benefit
mexico's economy eventually
it did exactly the opposite american
settlers
fled into texas onto this newly rented
land just as the mexican government
hoped for
but with them they brought slaves which
was totally illegal in mexico at the
time
they also brought with them an attitude
of independence and
frontier fever this american obsession
with moving west to settle new land
the westward movement was like a great
tidal wave
the odd corners were rapidly engulfed
mexico soon realized that this
plan completely backfired and that the
americans that had rented land from them
were now not interested in having mexico
as their government
so mexico sends in the military to
remind the settlers that they're still
in mexico
and that they're technically renting
this land from mexico
well this eventually escalated and they
started to fight all-out
battles and the american settlers lost
the big battle here was called the
battle of the alamo
this guy david crockett who was like the
symbol of westward expansion
died in this battle and this loss
spurred even more settlers to come to
texas and
join the next fight against mexico which
the american settlers won
and with that they declared a new nation
independent of mexico the
republic of texas now the map looks like
this
a newly declared country of american
settlers in between
mexico and the united states
[Music]
but not everyone actually agreed that
the map looked like this
while mexico conceded that they lost the
war
they disputed this map saying that the
border of the new republic of texas was
actually
here and that all of this was still
mexico
so now you have a big land dispute
between mexico and the republic of texas
well soon it's 1845 and texas becomes
the 28th state of the united states
and yet this land is still disputed but
now it's a land dispute between
the united states of america and mexico
let's keep in mind that despite all of
this map drawing
there are still loads of native peoples
who have lived on this land for years
and are now being suffocated by all
these nations trying to take their land
again that's another episode and it's an
important episode and
i want to do it justice but for now what
happens next in the mexico story
gets kind of nuts
and the reason it gets kind of nuts is
mainly because
of this guy president james k polk
james polk wins the presidency and comes
into office with
a list of four big things he wants to do
it's his big wish list
at the top of this wish list is polk's
desire
to capture this very specific part of
mexico which is called california
remember that at the time the u.s
didn't actually stretch from the
atlantic to the pacific the us had
colonized portions of oregon territory
but
it was kind of confusing because they
were kind of competing with the french
and the british and they didn't actually
own it yet but you'll notice that oregon
was also on polk's shortlist
but first california he first tried to
buy california from mexico for 25
million dollars
mexico flat out said no so polk decides
to pull an incredibly dirty move
remember this big old swath of disputed
territory that the us inherited when
they admitted texas into the union
james polk was pissed off that mexico
didn't take his offer to buy california
so he sends a small group of troops
into this disputed territory and has
them march
right up to here right across from the
river that
separates what everyone agrees is mexico
but according to mexico
they've already been in mexico as soon
as they crossed into this disputed
territory which
mexico believes is theirs so the mexican
army is sent to respond to what looks
like an oncoming attack from the united
states
this is exactly what polk wanted a group
of 1600 mexican soldiers
attack this small group of 80 americans
killing 11 of them
and capturing the rest they easily won
since they were outnumbered by like a
magnitude of
like 20. but this is exactly what polk
needed to get his wish list going after
this battle
polk goes to congress and reports that
the mexicans have quote
invaded our territory and shed american
blood
upon american soil even though this
wasn't necessarily american soil it was
disputed territory that most people
thought was rightfully mexico but it
didn't matter
the death of americans was enough to
rally congress around declaring war with
mexico
the u.s easily won this war and they did
it pretty quickly remember that
the taking over of texas was originally
a bunch of settlers who band together
made a militia fought mexico on their
own
and declared the republic of texas not
super great but
at least it wasn't like a government
leader sending his soldiers in that he
knows are going to lose
to provoke another country to kill those
soldiers so that he can use
democratic processes and institutions to
make war
all so that he can take over land from
that country i mean
polk really wanted california jeez there
were critics of this at the time
one of whom was this guy who said that
letting polk force the country into war
with mexico
was quote allowing him to make war at
pleasure
and abe hit the nail on the head this
whole war was started
and fought at the pleasure of this
president james k
polk so anyway the u.s easily wins the
war they pay
mexico 15 million dollars and mexico
gave up
all of this as a part of this loss
mexico also conceded
all of this disputed territory making it
officially a part of the us state of
texas
the u.s had grown significantly in just
a couple of years
and polk got his california the u.s
could have taken more land
some american lawmakers at the time
wanted to take all of mexico
and militarily they likely could have
done this but they only took
this part of mexico because it was the
most sparsely
populated mainly by native americans one
senator at the time who happened to be
pro-slavery argued on the senate floor
against taking all of mexico saying
quote
we have never dreamt of incorporating
into the union any but the caucasian
race
the free white race are we to associate
with ourselves as equal companions and
fellow citizens
the indians and mixed races of mexico in
other words let me put it plainly
the policy was let's search for land
where we can exterminate the natives
and settle white people instead of let's
take
land where there's already big
populations that are non-white people
that we would have to bring into our
country
this is a policy that informed american
expansion and imperialism
for a very long time and it's what
guided a lot of what land we took over
and what land we didn't take over
okay so through this unprovoked racially
tinged war
polk checked off california from his
list and just the next month
oregon was organized into a territory
after working out a deal with the
british
polk had exterminated anyone in his way
and now
he had a coast-to-coast country a few
years later they bought this little
piece of land from mexico
and this completed the southern border
that we know today
one that was forged first from a
rebellion of american settlers
then a war at the pleasure of james k
polk and then finally that little
purchase there at the end the native
people and mexicans that lived here when
the u.s took it over
and let's be clear on something that is
not a small number
they were predictably oppressed as white
settlers fled into this region
often looking for gold native people
were driven from their land
and the rights of mexican property
owners were erased in the name
of a state constitution that only let
white people vote
this land after a little more than a
century and a half
had become a great nation the united
states of america
so the u.s stole mexico in the 1800s
partly because they opened their borders
to americans
to let them in to work their land which
is just
a very strange full circle irony
especially because today you go to the
u.s mexico border
and we do everything to make it clear
that
this side of that wall is the u.s when
just a few years ago
it was all mexico i wish like the hawaii
video i had some
high note to end on here but i don't
so see ya
[Music]
these stories about how the u.s expanded
teach me
so much about how the u.s got its shape
and how the world works
and how countries grow and change and
i've really been learning a lot by
delving into these
before you go i want to tell you about a
really important resource online called
skillshare who's the sponsor of this
video but more importantly skillshare is
a platform that i've used for many years
to
learn a lot of the skills that i used in
today's video and i'm always using
animation video design all of these
things
i taught myself i didn't go to school
for skillshare was a key part of that
education i've taken
loads of skillshare courses over the
years well before they came
to sponsor a video and i'm just i really
believe in this model and you can get
two months of unlimited access to all
skillshare tutorials
for free if you click the link in my
description
which when you click that link it helps
support this channel but more
importantly it kick-starts your ability
to start learning new skills
if you're looking for a course to try
out i want to recommend this course
on animation loops it's called creating
crazy animation loops
in after effects this course really lays
out step by step how you can concept
and design interesting designs but then
how you can loop them
in ways that create a much more powerful
and interesting animation
so check that out but honestly
skillshare has courses of
all kinds not just animation and video
but like cooking and entrepreneurship
and like a million different topics
thousands of courses
you can get access to all of them for
free for two months if you click that
link and then after that it's like
i think less than 10 bucks a month if
you do the annual subscription which
for what you're getting like i'm sorry
it's like it's like a full-on education
in like creative arts and you're getting
that for 10 bucks a month like
seems like a no-brainer that's just me i
love learning on the internet so
um check out that link thank you
skillshare for sponsoring this video and
supporting this channel thank you all
for supporting this channel by being
here and leaving your feedback
and i will see you in the next video see
you later